what's up Wolfgang so ever since
Avengers infinity war came out people
have been blaming Thanos to snap on
certain characters we've all heard that
at Star Lords fault that it's Thor's
fault for not aiming for the head or the
arm and we've even heard that it could
be dr. Strange's fault for giving him
the time stone of course I don't think
any of these are true I think they were
all a part of dr. Strange's plan and
everything went exactly as it was
supposed to but after thinking enough
about the movie and other MCU movies and
thinking about what happens in between
movies that you don't really see
on-screen but are implied I actually
think that you can blame one character
and that character is Loki beg your
pardon and in this video I'm going to
tell you exactly why I think it's all
Loki's fault just a heads up the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway still
continues I'll be giving away a few more
copy still all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below your thoughts in
the video and your favorite superhero
okay so here's why I think that it's
Loki's fault
I did a video not too long ago talking
about wife Ana's waited to collect all
of the Infinity stones basically why he
waited was he waited until he knew where
all of the Infinity stones were because
according to Joe Russo the second he
goes after the Infinity stones the
forces of the universe would team
together and go against him
[Music]
I don't think he was talking about the
Avengers I think he was probably talking
about cosmic beans and others of just
massive strength whether that be
physical magical both anything now we
haven't really been introduced to any
cosmic beans in the MCU yet but there is
one person who is far superior in
strength that could easily defeat Thanos
in my opinion if he doesn't have all the
Infinity stones that is but who I'm
referring to is Odin I think Odin could
easily take on Thanos especially if he
had no Infinity stones yet he could
probably even take him on if he had up
to five Infinity stones he's done it
before in the comics he's taken on both
Thanos and the Silver Surfer at the same
time like it was no big deal
Odin is so strong with his Odin force
that he even went head-to-head with
Galactus so Thanos was waiting to
collect all the Infinity stones because
he knew that forces like Odin were going
to come after him and he probably would
have went after Thanos and he most
likely would have stopped him if he
weren't dead because of Loki it's not
100% clear how Odin dies and thor
ragnarok but even Thor blames Loki for
the death of Odin it's widely believed
that Loki stripped Odin of his powers
with the spell that he put on him and
being stripped of his powers and
separated from Asgard left Odin in a
weakened state I personally believe that
Odin could have recovered but did not
want to I think he chose to die if we
want to call it that and go to Valhalla
so he could be with his wife Frigga but
even then it's still Loki's fault
because he put him in that weakened
state to make Odin really just decide to
throw in the towel so anyway you really
look at it it's Loki's fault
and since Odin could have really stopped
Thanos at any point in time during his
pursuit of all the Infinity stones the
snap is Loki's fault
hey this is my personal belief knowing
how strong Odin is and knowing what Joe
Russo had to say about wife Anna's
waited to collect all the Infinity
stones what do you all think do you
think Odin could have defeated daños and
if so do you think it's Loki's fault
that Thanos was successful in collecting
all of the Infinity stones and
successful with his snap let me know
your thoughts in the comments below
another reminder about the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf amen we're about to jump on
that ginormous spaceship you want to
come well you do seem like you're in
desperate need of leadership boys thank
you
[Music]